and dude your teeth are wiped off it's
contrast
the same but it's contrast pranks
push-ups and dance challenges
are just a few of the things that keep
the this is us gang feeling like the
closest cast on tv
the only thing the pearsons know how to
do as well as cry is laugh which is
bound to happen when you have an acting
family that loves each other as much as
these guys do
their bromances melting prosthetics
pranks that have ruined a few good takes
and filming season 5 looks downright
crazy here's what the cast has revealed
about their best on-set blunders and
bloopers
plus how they feel about becoming
unintentional family therapists
oh and be careful if you aren't caught
up on the series because there are
spoilers ahead
the pearson siblings are like any normal
family and that means that to stay in
character the cast is constantly
messaging each other
during a photo shoot with the hollywood
reporter chrissy metz decided to do what
any good sister would
and push her unsuspecting brothers into
the pool
justin hartley and sterling k brown are
used to being on the receiving end of a
pearson family prank
since their on-screen dad has pulled one
over on them a few times
like when milo ventamilia couldn't
resist a prank in the middle of filming
when kevin and randall were having a
heart-to-heart in a car the duos started
talking about how they wished their
father was still around
milo took this as his cue to run up
alongside the car and remind his sons he
was just chilling backstage
justin and sterling took it like champs
but justin admits it probably ruined his
best take
we're talking and all of a sudden this
guy starts doing it
the actors who portray the pearsons wish
these beloved characters were real just
like the rest of us
that's why they get the cast and crew
together for dinners and hangouts just
like the real pearson family gatherings
the cast are the first to tell you that
these dinners are full of laughter and
discussions about the juicy twist the
show has in store for us next
so our only question now is what do we
got to do to get an invite
the cast tries to instill a little
laughter into everything they do on set
to help them get through the show's most
emotional scenes this has resulted in a
new on-set hobby
tick-tock challenges complete with full
pearson family wardrobe the whole cast
got in on the smees challenge
looks like the pearson's got some moves
any chance they'll become
tick-tock famous sterling k brown and
susan kalechi watson also decided to try
out drake's in my feelings challenge
they busted some moves that we're sure
their tv children would be mortified by
but we're more than happy to have it on
repeat
the cast might spend pretty much every
waking moment together while filming but
even after five seasons they have a
little trouble remembering how to spell
milo's last name
v-e-n-t-i-g
but don't worry at least his tv wife
managed to ace the test
been to mig l-i-a yeah
season five is looking a little
different on the set of this is us
since new safety measures have pretty
much restricted any physical contact
between the actors
chairs are separated by plexiglas
barriers so each cast member has their
own plastic box to chill in before
filming
which kind of looks like a zoo for
actors the show's creator dan fogelman
also posted a picture of milo and mandy
social distancing
and joked that the intimacy on tv is
going to look a lot different in 2020
speaking of season 5 mandy moore will be
wearing a lot of prosthetics as the
season explores rebecca
living with alzheimer's the cast combats
these scenes with laughter and joy
every time the director yells cut but
laughing isn't always so easy for mandy
and it has everything to do with all
that gunk on her face
mandy sometimes has to hide away to
avoid laughing between
scenes so she doesn't accidentally rip
her face off which is a product of four
hours in hair and makeup
mandy blames sterling justin and chris
sullivan for making her laugh the most
and i can't laugh with those prosthetics
oh that's right we're
like ripping your face off totally
exactly but it's hard to avoid disaster
with prosthetics on because it's not the
only thing that can send her back to the
makeup chair
sometimes a few tears can make her face
start to melt which when you imagine it
is a little less this is us and a lot
more
american horror story this is us
has also had some problems with mother
nature milo recalls one
onset moment when everyone was watching
mandy and sterling film an emotional
scene outside
when suddenly sterling had to stop to
point out that a bird had pooped on
mandy's hat
hold on i know you're in the zone but a
bird
just defecated on your head but mandy's
a pro
so after being ushered off stage for a
quick hat change she popped back into
the scene like nothing happened
and then they popped right back in the
moment i'm like oh my god i would have
lost i would have lost my mind
speaking of mandy her tv hubby has
nothing but good things to say
but we're not surprised our favorite
on-screen couple
who have the impressive superpower of
making us go from laughter to tears and
back again
all within a two-minute scene have the
most fun when they're on camera together
milo and mandy who we'll refer to as
eminem from now on because they're so
delicious
gush about each other all the time
you're
protective and you're practical like
what's a better word for kind you're the
team leader
thank you milo says mandy is just as
nice as she seems but she's also hard on
herself
as for milo mandy says he's the best
co-star and awesome tv dad
but he has the biggest potty mouth
apparently he drops f-bombs so often
they should start a swear jar
as for eminem's best kept behind the
scenes secret that would be their candy
stash which they always keep attached to
their chairs in case they need a
scene pick me up it's not like nuts and
dried fruits no no no no
no no it's like the hardcore sugar stuff
yeah the two are also great at
collaborating on things that aren't
acting
like when they showed off their musical
skills to glamour by wrapping the fresh
prince theme song
i looked at my kingdom i was finally
there to sit on my throne as the prince
of bel air
it might seem like all laughs but you're
definitely wondering how this cast isn't
constantly in tears having to portray
such heartbreaking moments
why don't you take a guess about which
castmate cries the most on set
the cast consensus is in and it's
definitely mandy moore
but mandy's also a goofball behind the
scenes she even uses rebecca's pregnancy
belly as her own portable table for
on-set lunches and script reviews
it's all about practicality people
eminem aren't the only two with an
unbreakable bond
justin and sterling are man crushing on
each other all the time
according to justin sterling's the
show's real heartthrob
sterling humbly disagrees complimenting
justin on his white teeth
perfectly quaffed hair and says that
touching him it's like brushing up
against a rock
oh my god we'd definitely like to find
that last one out for ourselves
to bond the pearson bros have started a
push-up challenge meant to resemble the
one jack does with randall when he's a
kid
milo and sterling gave it a go and then
justin had to get in on the action
feel free to drop a heart in the
comments if you wish you were up next
toby is definitely not to be excluded
from the brotherly bonding
in fact chris sullivan and justin can't
stop cracking each other up behind the
scenes
and sometimes on camera justin says he
often breaks character with chris
because they do a lot of ad-libbing in
one scene where kevin admits that he
hasn't seen notting hill there are
outtakes of toby shaking him and
freaking out in disbelief which led to
justin breaking character more than a
few times
there was one take where he literally
grabbed me he's like what
and it was like shaking me and then he
hit me do you ever watch this as us as a
replacement for your own therapy session
well you're not the only one his journey
his bonding with his father and stuff
like that
um it's kind of a therapy because fans
sometimes come up to the cast for a
little one-on-one counseling
sterling reveals that people often
expect hugs and feel like they're
already
friends oh okay we're hugging
it's like they're not just actors but
also accidental family therapists
for chrissy metz this passion can come
out in different ways
like people threatening to sue nbc if
kate left toby at the altar
um people were like i will abandon this
show i will sue
nbc if you've wondered who gets to see
the most shocking this is us episodes
before everyone else
it turns out that paramount studios
dedicates a whole room to secret
pre-season screenings where a dozen
family and friends get to give feedback
on the show's biggest twists
dan fogelman says this doesn't always
work out quite as intended
when they revealed that jack finally
made it out of that devastating house
fire
the audience was too busy wondering
where all the fire trucks were and why
no one was calling 9-1-1
not exactly the speechless reaction they
were hoping for
speaking of twists and turns we might be
surprised by all the new drama
introduced each season but all of the
show's biggest twists were planned out
way before the series
even started filming as for what we can
look forward to in season five
fogelman promises that we'll explore the
story of randall's birth mother
experience rebecca living with
alzheimer's and explore the struggles of
marriage with toby and kate
but drama aside the season will be
filled with the pearson family love that
makes us feel
all warm and gooey inside do you have a
favorite behind the scenes moment
let us know all your thoughts and what
you expect from season 5 in the comments
don't forget to hit that like button if
you want more this is us content
and subscribe to our channel thanks for
watching